[Music]
and in played yourself news submitted by
playground rules
a man with chars after tying himself to
a chair and faking his own kidnapping is
it Jesse Smollett
[Music]
yeah so we have talked about you know
self kidnapping attempts but here's a
new one so this guy he's 45 years old he
is from Wisconsin and he was texting his
wife telling him telling her that he has
been held against his will and he was
sending demands as the kidnappers and so
she ended up calling the police and they
went to his workplace and so when they
went went around back the door was open
and they were able to they found him in
a chair would zip-tie called zip tied up
tied up and he's a good job at his job
supervisor hmm yeah they're just saying
that they walked into the business where
he was and he was strapped to a chair
with zip ties because he was yelling as
well was it sexual his dick was awesome
no no it wasn't for money because he's
robbing from his own bank account yeah
pretty much
so he's tied up but he has the
wherewithal to have his phone in text
did he tie himself just like this it
ends he still had a cell phone so he was
tied like this maybe like it at first
you like texted first things like all
they're gonna come oh you can grab the
self-locking ones where you grab the
insides and you he's easy there yeah
yeah come on with that [ __ ] where's the
body Ryan you know interesting
Ryan ties himself up he takes a long
time other people are okay yeah I do
no no he's into that Japanese rope
bondage where he hangs
Tice people and he hangs them up that's
a thing people hang you timeout maybe
that's like a thing in bondage yeah yes
I don't know it's like it sounds tiny
they what do you call it a night
hog-tie um hog-tie them and tie them all
up and then strap them up I tell you
what I think about that would make me
think now I want to
but it makes people horny if it floats
your boat
yeah I don't know the whole hog type
thing so so what did you wanted to do it
were you like whoa just think I found
out someone did then I was like how was
that I want to be a trisexual what is it
triceps
yeah you try the [ __ ] out of everything
you want to do you see the peg what is
that
maybe if I have a loose [ __ ] let's
maybe if I'm 70 girl puts a strap-on and
then gets top of your ass no when I'm 70
when you're 70 cuz your [ __ ] be
tender by then that's right oh it's just
loosen like mine and it's too tight I'm
not even that adventurous sexually like
that but what if you get bored though at
70 that way then like start looking at
dogs like hmm you said everything you
said you were gonna try everyone right
now it gotta [ __ ] got a limitation of
try everything that's legal
you have to do it I know but if I'm in
Virginia it's legal there you can marry
everything I was in Amsterdam I went to
the red light district I tried to
partake in it do that for Tyler yeah I
paid for that but I couldn't do it
I paid well paid and you said like it's
like they're all in these little windows
it's like shopping and there are these
red windows but you got to be careful
because if it's a blue light it too dude
so you have to be careful what if she
was fine as [ __ ] went so I'm walking
around and I'm like window shopping on
my god
there's a tip with it probably the
ladies he kind of likes when W is an
odor like Jamaica Bay she was like yeah
boy I got it I do you free
you're like that's the one so I go in
there and so I'm just like I so she's
like a hund'd dollahs what you said for
free though I know she's definitely big
switch so then so I give her the hundred
dollars but then I just got all in my
head I was like regulated bro never been
testing and how did you not go for the
hot ones man I was going to but it was
like almost like aunt like when you're
browsing stuff on Netflix you can sit
there for two hours like they haven't
watched anything I went there it's like
right it's also so I go you know I just
couldn't do it cuz I knew I had to use a
condom I couldn't have sex with the girl
without a collar that would have been
crazy so and then I was like trying to
get in I was like trying to put it on
that was like me use the time to talk
now I'm so cheap even if I was like
alright you know I paid for this we're
talking about my feelings now [ __ ] this
you're gonna be my therapist or I'm just
gonna interview that and [ __ ] was super
cool she was like no just take your time
yeah I got all night you are baby babe
oh I was like that's so what is how much
do you get timed on it or like I wasn't
really trippin off time I may not guess
it's what is she charged under dollars
for she said I could have got a B I
could have got I can add sex and hit C
that you get everything all encompassed
everything but it was just like it just
got I think it's okay if you don't get
in your head about it like once I got in
my head like I don't know who I was with
a bunch of bruises all the other one who
went there well I'm the only one that I
know wins I don't know what anybody else
did but I know I went and I tried to do
it I also ate a banana out of a ditch
beside people they have sex in front of
you and if she put a she put the banana
in her vagina
scared of STDs because that's the thing
it was she unpeel to banana she stuck
the part that was still peeled in her so
I bit the part that never touched her I
see I just didn't want to ruin the clean
banana then oh yeah well I don't know
you know because if so she had brought
us on stage and so I took a bite he
wouldn't even about he like took a piece
off wash before they you don't peel all
of them banana and stuff you know what I
can't say about Amsterdam that she would
actually be surprised about the weed was
tries oh really that's how we feel about
the beer in England and all and then
Germany and all those politely I don't
give a [ __ ] let's have the best beer I
thought it was gonna be like I wouldn't
know I want to try Japanese whiskey it's
[ __ ] Volvo I'll bring some I don't
want some no that's different that's
like rice wine shochu is like a
unfiltered rice wine that's that's a
little bit different but they're whiskey
whiskey made out of like barley like
other different kinds of like grains and
stuff like that yeah so what ended up
happened to the guy did he get caught
sky he so once the cops showed up and
they were questioning him he said that
he just got not like to knock down
unconscious woke up several minutes
later and he was just tied to the chair
inside that business and so the cops
were like you know it's just not adding
up so the no investigating and like
eventually this dude broke and said okay
he's just my wife and I have been having
problems and I thought she would care
about me so yes I saved this whole thing
it's a hoax oh my god did he go to job
of that yeah so he got booked for for
kidnapping for charges on obstructing an
officer and unlawful use of a phone yeah
what well it's cuz they called it they
called or they you've had a hoax and
then they call the police and they
wasted their time and wasted emergency
services time but see this not [ __ ] up
part about it if she was already
thinking he was a weak spineless guy
before yeah he's definitely
now hell no she's like you first thing
that would drive me to the divorce
office it's like you're such a little
[ __ ] you got kidnapped and tied and you
did it yourself yourself and the you
shove dildos in your mouth and [ __ ] they
rape me with good excuse like other
people would look at the situation and
be like oh that's so sweet you're all
that trouble where's your attention girl
say not long ago she was like did you
know that show you on Netflix is about
the dude that's like a stalk to each
other for mr. Palin she was like I mean
this might be a popular but I actually
think that's kind of attractive I'm uh I
mean this look at all the time and
everybody put in a stocking here as well
she said that she said that she thought
that that was attractive that he went
through so much Cheney Brothers woman
that was his life well she's used to
guys that don't text her back and stuff
and she's like a dream it was so savage
but um they were like I forgot the
wording I'm gonna butcher it but the
point of the whole tweet is that someone
was saying like would you break up with
your boyfriend if he made like if you
cheated on you and got some other girl
pregnant and then made her get an
abortion and then the response was like
well at least he like you know he'll
kill for you we do another jakey news
about a lady that did the same thing and
it seems pretty common where like people
always fake kidnapping like do they
think they're not gonna get caught but
they want to see if they care about them
tell me how much you can't thank the
people that would fake their death just
to see who like how shows up yeah I'm
actually the opposite like the more
desperate you are the more I want to run
away from you yeah yeah it's like you're
not working hard to me that's you're
working hard to manipulate me that's how
you find out about the manipulation
they're thinking that you all find out
about the manipulation
yeah like when I when I get told about
problems like oh no this happened to me
like oh I was I was stranded at the bus
and I'm like you're just turning me off
even more because you saw more and more
stupid like you got stranded now you're
what
damn you couldn't figure yourself out of
that situation see yeah there's actually
a clinical thing about that that they
say like more people will stop and help
you like so if you just stand on the
side of the road just sitting there
people will just pass you by but if
you're just on the side of road and
you're like pushing your car more people
will be inclined to pull over and push
the with you because they see you doing
something like if you're just standing
there and like asking for money versus
the guy that selling roses row watch
them try to watch when you lose it yeah
we're doing something we're dancing
that's my favorite one if they're
dancing dad you got my money man the guy
in the wheelchair there's one particular
thing enough he's in a wheelchair and
then when the car pulls up and they're
two lanes over he gets up out of the
wheelchair and he walks over them are
you no problem no lip nothing he just
walked right over and he takes it from
the window order oh yeah paying for you
to sit out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]